- He should have let me
bump off Harvey Dent.
We'd all have been better
off. Wouldn't we, Harv?
- Yeah, you can't defend
your attempted murder
by saying that everyone
would be better off
if you actually completed
the murder itself.
(upbeat music)
Today, we're gonna take a
deep dive into my childhood
with one of my favorite shows of all time,
"Batman: The Animated Series."
- You know, as a kid I used
to watch it with my father.
- I'm a real lawyer,
so let's react to "Batman:
The Animated Series,"
the "Trial" episode.
(dramatic music)
♪ Doodele doo doo ♪
(thunder crashing)
All right, "Trail."
No, I'm sorry. "Trial."
The "Trial" episode.
All right, Paul Dini and Bruce W. Timm,
we'll see if you can write
a good courtroom episode.
- [Judge] Pamela Lillian Isley,
District Attorney Van Dorn has asked
that the maximum sentence
of life imprisonment
be imposed upon you.
- Maximum sentence for what?
In "Batman: The Animated Series,"
I don't think anyone ever actually dies,
and I don't think Poison Ivy,
I think this is a Poison Ivy, right?
So...
- Call me Poison Ivy.
- What is she getting the maximum sentence
of life in prison for?
I mean, I guess maybe attempted murder.
She did try and kill a lot of people.
All right. All right.
So if she was, I don't know
what the particular
circumstances are here,
but the district attorney has asked
for the maximum sentence.
I don't know that that fits
with the sentencing guidelines,
even though this is New York state,
not actually the federal system,
but I'll allow it, I'll allow it.
- [Judge] However, as
your apprehension came
at the hands of the Batman
and not a recognized agent of the law,
this court has no choice.
- Okay. All right.
A couple of big problems here.
First of all, we've talked
a lot on this channel
about how Batman is a vigilante,
the things he's doing are illegal,
and subjects him to all kinds
of actual criminal penalties.
Putting that aside, when
Batman apprehends a wrongdoer
who has also done something wrong,
that doesn't mean that
they don't go to jail.
They can be sentenced to
jail just like anyone else.
The fact that a vigilante
has captured them,
I don't think has any actual repercussions
in the actual police and
judicial system itself.
- [Judge] This court has no choice
but to return you to Arkham Asylum,
where it is hoped you will
complete your rehabilitation.
- Okay, but what does that
have to do with anything?
So if they're captured by Batman,
going to Arkham Asylum
is effectively the result
of being found guilty of a crime.
Now, Arkham Asylum, my recollection
is that it's a mental institution,
and if you're found not
guilty by reason of insanity,
which a lot of these, I
guess, supervillains are,
you could be sent to some
sort of facility like that,
but it's for an indefinite amount of time.
But what the judge is saying
is a non-sequitur here.
He's saying we can't do anything with you
because you were captured by Batman,
but also I'm gonna send you
to this mental institution
because you're not guilty
by mental insanity.
I don't know what's going here.
So far, this doesn't check out.
(keys clinking)
(dramatic music)
(door clicking)
You know, for a mental institute,
this looks a lot like a prison.
I think they're blurring some lines here
between a mental institution
and just a flat-out supermax prison here.
- Well, cheer up!
Word is, we're gonna throw a little party!
And old Jervis here has the invitations!
- I mean, I suppose it does make sense
that the Mad Hatter does
reside in Arkham Asylum,
more so than anyone else.
I have no reason to believe
why all of those other criminals
should be in Arkham Asylum
instead of, you know, an actual prison.
- Not only does Batman create
these so-called super criminals,
he takes it upon himself
to be their judge and jury
with no regard for the legal system.
- Well, that's not true.
Batman literally leaves the
prisoners on the doorstep
of the police so that the
police can arrest the prisoners,
and then theoretically,
they'll be tried by the district attorney,
who once was Harvey Dent,
and now is Miss Van Dorn.
Yeah, I don't think I agree with that.
I think that's unnecessarily cynical.
- [Reporter] It sounds like
you wan to put Batman on trial.
- Believe me, I'd like nothing better.
- Well, yeah, so look,
Batman deserves to be on trial
for a whole host of reasons
that are apart from the fact
that he's judge, jury, and executioner.
He's not really any of those things.
He is a vigilante, and
should be put on trial,
but that's sort of neither here nor there.
- As Gotham's new district attorney,
I can't allow your pet nut
to run loose in my city.
- Yeah, that's fair.
- I mean it!
- Janet, it's a war zone out there,
and Batman is our best weapon.
- That's also fair.
- And I say, he's a drug
the city keeps taking
to avoid facing reality.
Speak of the devil.
- The East Side Skulls
are ready to declare war
on the other gangs.
- Old news, my department's
already planning a sting
to catch the Skulls' leader.
- Don't bother.
(blinds rattling)
(Devin laughs)
- Very cute, mister.
- But so, I mean, the issue
with gangland violence
is not that you don't know
who the gang members are
and just you can go arrest them,
it's that you have to
actually have enough evidence
that they have done the things
that they were accused of.
And so here, Batman hasn't
done really much good
because he's just simply captured someone
that I'm sure the district
attorney and the police
already knew was a member
of this gang system.
So yeah, Batman not doing his best here.
- You want to support law and order,
you take off that mask
and put on a uniform.
- Yeah. I mean, that's fair.
- Next time I see him, it'll
be a whole different story.
- Hmmm. Will it, though?
- Hello, Bruce.
- Of course.
- Janet, I'm so glad
we're able to meet on such short notice.
Still, even you have to
admit Batman's come through
now and then.
- But look at the lunatic
fringe he's created,
the Joker, Two-Face,
Poison Ivy, and the rest,
Batman's responsible
for every one of them.
- Is he? So, okay.
Is that where this episode is going,
that Batman is actually responsible
for creating the supervillains
that he is policing as well?
I mean, ooh. Interesting.
Well, we'll see where that goes.
I mean, that might get into
issues of proximate cause
versus actual cause, but
that's kind of a straw man,
so it'll be interesting to
see what she does with that.
- I'm sorry, Bruce. I won't be a minute.
- Take your time.
- Is that a "I hate to see you go,
but I love watching you leave" joke?
Did they shoehorn that
into a kids' cartoon here?
Hmm, I wonder if they're
being a little cheeky there.
No pun intended.
- [Janet] Let me out! Do you hear me?
Whoever you are, let me out this second!
- Again, this really, really
looks like a prison here
rather than any kind of institute
that would actually be for psychological
or psychiatric purposes.
- We got some legal
business to settle first.
- What do you mean?
- I'm talking about a trial.
Me the prosecutor, you the defense,
and your client... (snaps fingers)
Is Batman.
- Okay, you know what?
I like the idea, I like
the setup of this episode,
making the single-minded district attorney
who actually doesn't
like Batman to be forced
to defend him.
Though it's interesting that
when these supervillains
finally have the upper hand,
they have Batman incapacitated,
they decide to do this legal nonsense
instead of, you know,
actually unmasking him
and, you know, killing him.
Yeah, not a great plan
from their perspective,
but a great conceit for an episode.
I love it.
- Far as I'm concerned, you
belong in here with them!
(Devon groans)
- (groans) Whatever.
You've gotta go through with it.
It's their game and their rules.
- You've said it yourself, lady.
Batman made every one of us.
- So we are placing him before
the bar to face our justice.
- Okay.
- Amusing idea, what,
kidnapping you to be Batman's attorney?
- Okay, so legally speaking,
putting aside the fact that
this trial is completely rigged
and impossible, this would
be a very, very easy case
for this lawyer to win
because just because
someone is an actual cause
doesn't mean that they
are the proximate cause,
the legal cause of something happening,
and when you're talking about
a bunch of supervillains
who are, I use this term loosely,
in control of their faculties,
they're committing a
bunch of intentional torts
and a bunch of intentional crimes.
So that Batman, though he
might have placed a domino
or flipped a domino over in
this long string of dominoes
that led to the creation
of these supervillains,
he's not actually
responsible for the things
that they have done.
So theoretically, this lawyer should have
a pretty easy time.
- [The Ventriloquist] Likewise
our fair and impartial jury.
- Hang him!
- Shoot him!
- Hit him with a rock!
- Okay, so I probably
don't need to tell you
that this jury is completely
constitutionally infirm.
First of all, you don't have 12 people,
which is not requirement in all states,
but generally you do have 12.
(laughs) This is not an
impartial selection of people
in this area.
Batman is not being tried
by a selection of his peers.
Under the Sixth Amendment,
a jury has to be a
representative cross sample
of the people in that
geographical location,
and not only is this petit jury,
the I think six
supervillains who are there,
not representative of
the community at large,
there was no jury panel,
there was no veneer through
which you could choose
the members of the jury.
It has to be impartial.
And it doesn't mean that
they can't know anything
about the accused,
but it does mean that they have to be able
to put what they know aside.
And here they are material witnesses,
they are absolutely not
impartial against Batman,
and so yeah. (laughs)
Believe it or not,
a jury made up exclusively
of supervillains
does not pass constitutional muster.
- Judge Joker!
(crowd cheering)
(gavel bangs)
- Guilty!
- Yeah, so Joker as the judge,
that doesn't pass
constitutional muster either.
He needs to be bounced
for not being capable
of presiding over this trial.
- I was promised a chance
to defend my client.
- Oh, very well.
Like it'll make a difference.
Mr. Prosecutor, make
your opening statement.
- Yeah, so in California,
you have a procedure through
which you ask the judge
to no longer preside over your trial,
and sometimes you can
just do it automatically.
It's called 170.6, and the judge,
after that particular section
of the California Code,
you definitely want to make a 170.6 motion
in this particular case.
- We're all freaks and monsters,
and who made us this way?
Batman!
(all shouting angrily)
- Yeah, not so much.
So in law school,
you spend a huge amount of time
talking about the difference
between actual cause
and proximate cause, and in fact,
often you're dealing
with really dry cases.
There is one particular case in law school
that I think is actually
really interesting
that talks about this very distinction.
It's called the Palsgraf case,
and it involves a guy
who brings some fireworks
onto a train, the box
of fireworks explodes,
and it tips over this giant
scale onto this poor woman
named Palsgraf, and so the
main question in that case
is not whether the guy
who brought the fireworks,
is he responsible, but the question is,
is the railroad at any point responsible?
And I actually did an entire video
called "What's in the Box?"
that talks about this very case.
It's all animated, which is fitting,
'cause this is "Batman:
The Animated Series."
So if you are curious about
how that case turned out
and the difference between
actual and proximate cause,
you can check out that video.
- Yo, Hat! On the stand!
- Yeah, right out of the
jury into the witness box.
That is not allowed.
- Proceed, counselor.
- You brainwashed and kidnapped
a woman who rejected you.
- Batman forced me to do it.
He was going to take her away
from me. I had no choice.
- Yeah, that's not an actual defense.
- You could have respected
her wishes and left her alone.
- I'd have killed her first!
Oooh, I'd like that last statement
stricken from the record, please.
- Record? Is someone supposed
to be writing this down?
- Yeah, well, someone is
supposed to be writing it down.
So I actually really liked
that cross-examination.
Well, actually, so was there,
there was no direct examination.
Yeah, so I guess we'll call
that cross examination.
That really actually
highlights the difference
between actual cause and proximate cause,
that yeah, Batman played a role in it,
but for the most part,
it was just Mad Hatter
being the Mad Hatter,
and he was committing intentional acts.
So this is actually a really fun example
of the distinction between
the two kinds of cause.
- I object to this witness.
She's obviously trying
to influence the judge.
- Yeah, that seems improper.
- What makes you say that?
- But of course, the writers know that,
they're making that exact joke.
- If there was no Batman,
there'd be no Joker,
and I'd never have met my puddin'!
Thank you, Batman!
- So that's not damages. That's a benefit.
- Puddin' here finked on you
in hopes of getting time off.
- Shhh!
- You lousy scuz-sucking creep!
- The witness is excused!
(audience laughing)
- I mean, the judge probably
should find her in contempt,
you know, and sentence her to
jail time for assaulting him.
But you know...
- And so it's Batman's fault
you lead a life of crime.
- He should've let me
bump off Harvey Dent.
We'd all have been better
off. Wouldn't we, Harv?
- Yeah, you can't defend
your attempted murder
by saying that everyone
would be better off
if you actually completed
the murder itself.
That's not an actual defense,
and it's not... (laughs)
It's not a way of actually
saying that the person
who stopped you from committing murder
is the actual criminal.
That's not a thing here.
- Then it doesn't bother you when someone,
let's say the judge
here, ruthlessly plucks
a defenseless flower from
the warm green earth.
- No.
- But aren't the Joker's flowers,
canonically, like they shoot acid?
They're made of plastic?
It's kind of convenient
that there's a real flower
in this particular case.
Real convenient there.
- One by one until it's all gone, honey.
(Poison Ivy screams)
(dramatic music)
- I mean, it doesn't
actually change anything.
- Please!
(audience grumbling)
- I used to believe Batman was
responsible for you people.
But now I see nearly everyone
here would have ended up
exactly the same, Batman or not.
- I mean, so that's true,
but I think we're still in the middle
of the cross-examination here.
So, you know, I know this
happens on TV all the time,
but you're not allowed to
actually make closing arguments
when you're supposed to
be questioning people.
That's sort of trial 101.
- Oh, the gimmicks might be different,
but you'd all be out there
in some form or another
bringing misery to Gotham.
The truth is, you created him.
- And of course, not for
nothing, there's no bailiff here,
and so the bailiff can't police the fact
that you're just walking
around the entire courtroom
'cause you know, you're not allowed
to actually enter the
well without permission
from the judge, I guess
even in Arkham Asylum.
Maybe, maybe, I don't know.
- Jury, you've heard the
evidence. Consider your verdict.
- So again, in real life, this
is not a close case at all.
Batman is not responsible for the actions
of the supervillains.
He has, however, committed
all kinds of other crimes,
not related to these supervillains,
but that's a subject
for a different video.
- In light of Ms. Van
Dorn's stirring defense,
we have no choice but to find
the defendant not guilty.
- Hey!
(audience shouting angrily)
How cool, so this episode is
a really wonderful exploration
of the difference between actual cause
and proximate cause.
They should actually
watch this in law schools
to talk about the difference.
This is way more interesting
than being in a law school lecture.
- You've proven that
Batman didn't create us,
that we in fact messed
up our own rotten lives.
And as we are so rotten,
vile, and depraved,
we're going to waste you anyway!
(Janet gasps)
(crowd shouting angrily)
- Yeah, so that's not
in the federal sentencing
guidelines either.
But yeah, you knew that.
(dramatic music)
Okay, hold on. Hold on.
So, (laughs) first of all,
why does a mental institution
have a electric chair,
because this is not a prison,
this is not a place where
people are sentenced to death.
There's no reason that
that should be there.
Also, whether Gotham
is New York or Chicago,
neither New York or Illinois
has had a death penalty for decades.
Now, I know this takes
place in (indistinct),
blah, blah, blah, but I don't care.
Neither New York City or Chicago
have the actual death penalty,
so no facilities, whether
they're actual prisons or not,
should have an electric
chair in them at all.
- I see now there's a need
for the things you do,
but I'm still going to work toward a city
that doesn't need Batman.
- Me too.
- Okay, fair enough.
So Batman escapes, and the
district attorney learns
that Batman is helpful.
Still, Batman is a vigilante
who is committing all kinds of crimes,
so I'm not sure that
this particular detente
is actually good for the city or not.
That depends on who you ask.
So Batman gets a happy ending
from the district attorney,
but will he get a happy ending from me?
Phrasing. Okay.
So this episode, pros and cons.
First of all, a great
exploration of the differences
between actual and proximate cause,
and that's about where the realism ends.
What makes it unrealistic,
completely unconstitutional jury,
completely rigged from the start,
and a premise that wouldn't even get past
a motion to dismiss.
So all in all, unfortunately
I'm gonna have to give
this episode a D minus for realism,
though an A+ in terms of
just being fun to watch.
- I always knew how to make an exit.
- Now, Batman is a guy
who knows a thing or two
about comfortable underwear.
After all, he wears them on the outside.
Now, I don't, but I do wear
Mack Weldon's incredibly
comfortable boxer briefs
on the inside.
See? (grunts)
Mack Weldon is known
for their insanely
comfortable boxer briefs,
including their new stealth boxer briefs.
It's so comfortable, I wear two. (grunts)
Oh, these are great for everything
from working out to hanging
out, and it feels like nothing,
like you're not wearing
a second boxer brief.
And if you're watching this channel,
you're an adult, and you probably deserve
to have nice boxer briefs.
And I can tell you, it
makes a world of difference.
And I also love Mack
Weldon's Radius Pants,
which are halfway between
slacks and joggers.
They are also insanely comfortable.
They're for the man who
can wear sweat pants,
but doesn't want to.
Now, if I'm not in court or
on a Zoom call with the judge,
I'm often wearing Mack Weldon.
They focus on smart design
and premium fabrics.
I order in multiple sizes,
have them shipped to my home,
because who has time
to go clothes shopping,
and then just return the
ones that don't fit right
and keep the ones that fit perfectly.
And with Mack Weldon's loyalty program,
you can get a discount, free shipping,
and access to new products.
It's automatic when you sign up and order
at Mack weldon.com/legaleagle.
Now, if you would like to try Mack Weldon,
Legal Eagles like you will
get 20% off their first order,
just by going to
MackWeldon.com/legaleagle,
and using the promo code
LegalEagle at checkout.
Or just click on the link
that's on screen right now.
So just click on that link to
get 20% off your first order,
but remember to use that
promo code, LegalEagle,
plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist for
all of my other reactions,
where I'll see you in court.